[Music]
over the past two decades k-12 school
reform has been dominated by testing
standards and charter schooling those
have been the fault lines in the
education reform Wars well we've come to
a pivot point the new center of gravity
mindset and erase this shift was made
explicit in my annual education scholar
rankings which this year made clear a
changing of the guard
not just in policy and public opinion
but even in terms of who gets hailed as
an expert in terms of book sales media
coverage and more the shift is not from
advocates to critics of yesterday's
reforms it's a matter of a shift away
from one set of reforms and towards a
new set of priorities education is big
shift is not just about new legislation
political agendas and public opinion but
it extends to who gets celebrated as an
expert that has big implications for
what research gets conducted and which
ideas are likely to shape the national
discourse in the decade to come what do
you think is the most promising reform
to improve American schooling let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI